[Musique]
j'ai grandi dans une famille sur la
scène lara à québec
mon père est architecte naval et puis je
les suit dans ses traces
johnston est un architecte naval qui a
fait construire plus de 50 navires dans
sa carrière il a mené des contrats de
plus d'un milliard de dollars sur des
chantiers navals partout dans le monde
vous en avez fait plein de bateaux qui
vont qui n'avait dans toutes sortes de
conditions partout dans le monde sur le
saint laurent en art c'est qu'on en
sorte que dans le milieu maritime sa
réputation est impeccable il se
spécialise dans les bateaux classés pour
naviguer dans la glace comme ce qu'il a
fait construire pour fait nav un
armateur québécois lignac et le nunavik
les plus puissants vrac hybris tard ce
monde navigue sans escorte l'année
durant afin de ravitailler délit
et d'acheminer leurs productions vers
les marchés mondiaux
[Musique]
jones top 10 nous a contactés à la suite
de la diffusion de notre reportage sur
le f à gauthier en septembre parce que
ce qu'il a vu et entendu lui a fait
dresser les cheveux sur la tête c'est la
faulx est-ce que c'est sa pièce
d'équipement là vous voyez un
rapprochement rouge pour survivre à la
fin où les dirigeants de la société des
traversiers nous avait fait visiter le
chantier
c'est ici que l'on a remonté les
propulseurs fabriqués par ce tir prat
c'est cette pièce qui cause l'arrêt du f
à gauthier depuis décembre de l'an
dernier pour vous retourner un navire en
bonne forme avant le début de l'hiver
nous vous révélions qu'avec les imprévus
laventure du ffa gauthier a déjà coûté
260 millions de dollars aux québécois
notre expert dit que ce qu'il voit dans
nos images ce sont de grosses grosses
gaffes de conception du bateau
la carte des déficiences de djaffar
gauthier s'est scellée propulseurs qui
ne fonctionne pas que ce son qui se sont
brisés pour pour moi ce n'était pas
surprenant du tout le propulsion la
technologie éprouvée jusqu'à une
certaine jusqu'à une certaine cote de
glace en d'autres mots la sévérité de la
glace et puis jusqu'à une certaine
puissance mais dans le code du fr
gauthier ils sont allés dans l'inconnu
la cote de glace et puis le type de
propulseurs et la puissance est en fait
quelque chose qui n'avait jamais été
fait auparavant dans qui ont choisi les
m'avait propulsa pour ce type de bateau
là selon vous oui oui il ya les pros
question le risque était là risque était
énorme et puis on pas gagné leur pari
expérimenté saint-jean d'un risque
et puis pour un service essentiel comme
ça c'est pas l'endroit pour faire s'il
ya un endroit pour faire des
expérimentations ne sais pas si c'est
pas sur un bateau comme celui là l'autre
problème selon l'architecte naval
c'est cette pièce qu'on appelle le bulbe
d'étrave ce sommet marque et le fait
qu'ils ont mis un bulbe sur nos bateaux
c'était c'est un étrange c'est quoi
c'est quoi la le bulbe ici c'est cette
partie la projection en avant et puis sa
soeur
réduire la résistance donc la
consommation de carburant quatre bateaux
naviguent en eaux libres
[Musique]
quand on voit dans les glaces et triste
un aspect très négatif dans la
conception s'empêche de bateaux de
manoeuvre et plus particulièrement la
part de colt de matane est très connu
comme étant un port où la glace est
difficile en hiver mettre un bulbe sur
ce bateau là
ça me dépasse et il y à un autre très
gros problème selon l'expert il relayé
dans la conception de l'arrière du
navire pour protéger les propulseurs
quand on fait la conception d'un bateau
ont fait la conception avec des formes
dans la coque arrière pour empêcher le
pire de la glace de rentrer dans les
lices moi j'avais jamais vu le derrière
du navire jusqu'à ce que j'ai vu le
reportage d' enquête et puis j'étais
horrifié de voir la conception parce que
rien dans la conception du navire pour
protéger le défaut ici un grand très
anti palier plus derrière du navire ce
n'est pas réparable ça va se répéter à
l'avenir ça et puis ça va ça va se
répéter ou 3 4 1 pour la vie du bateau
ce que je vois c'est que la conception
été faite par des gens qui m a plus de
notion et puis et puis plus d'expérience
de bateaux dans les glaces c'est ce qui
ressort de regarder ça ne vas tout
fonctionne pas et puis il va toujours
être problématique toute sa vie c'est ce
que vous prédisez mais c'est ce que je
vois oui et la question qui tue combien
d'argent coûteront ces erreurs ou
contribuables québécois
si le bas tout métier le service pour
lequel il a été acheté en d'autres mots
travailler dans la glace assez difficile
le bateau va avoir des problèmes à
répétition toute sa vie et puis ça va
coûter plusieurs millions à chaque fois
et puis ça va ça va monter ça va siffler
dans les dizaines de millions quand on
se trompe au niveau de la conception les
coûts explosent et puis sont là pour la
vie et puis si dans le cas de ce bateau
là c'est nous les contribuables qui
payons mais ce système si vous étiez
dans la chaise du pdg de la société des
traversiers du québec là vous êtes vous
est pris avec ce bateau là qu'est ce que
vous feriez avec je demanderai beaucoup
d'argent au gouvernement parce que ça
m'apprend beaucoup
après avoir vidé une boîte de kleenex
à qui la faute entièrement à la société
des traversiers du québec selon john
stop
l'expert croit qu'ils avaient d'abord eu
la bonne idée d'aller en appel d'offres
international
mais qu'ils ont fait une grave erreur en
retenant le plus bas soumissionnaire et
en particulier d'avoir choisi le
chantier de castellammare di stabia du
groupe fincantieri en italie qui n'est
pas reconnu pour sa grande expérience en
construction de bateaux navigant dans la
glace au moins un chantier comme ça
contre des chantiers allemands que je
connais compte des chantiers finlandais
que je connais j'aurais même pas retenu
chantier dans ma liste de candidats
auraient laissé tomber même si les plus
beaux le sien parce que le risque était
trop élevé au final trois
soumissionnaires ont été retenu pour
construire le f à gauthier le deuxième
seulement 6 millions plus cher était un
chantier finlandais avec beaucoup plus
d'expérience
s'ils avaient payé la différence de prix
on aurait sauvé déjà de loin dans mon
expérience moi quand je travaille dans
le domaine on prenait jamais le plus
beau jamais prenait jamais le plus haut
prélat ceux qui tel un milieu pour la
même raison que j'ai dit tantôt leur
gestion de risque
nous avons redemandé une entrevue à la
société des traversiers qui ne veut rien
dire de plus pendant que la
vérificatrice générale enquête sur le f
à gauthier une question a été soulevée
plusieurs fois pourquoi ne pas avoir
fait construire le f à gauthier au
chantier des vies chez nous à lévis à
l'époque cela arrêter la pire des idées
selon les opinions nous avons recueilli
l'alliance entre la société des
traversiers avec le chantier des vies
qui avait beaucoup de problèmes avant sa
vente en 2012
au cous une catastrophe financière dont
on parle moins
le jo des chaînes 2 et le armand un beau
2-2 petit traversier qui relie
baie-sainte-catherine et tadoussac
le contrat a été donné sans appel
d'offres à la dvi et les coûts ont
explosé
ils sont montés 220 à 250 millions et
jusqu à 324 millions de dollars avec
quatre ans de retard
la société des traversiers la davis se
sont accusés mutuellement d'être
responsables des dépassements de coûts
mais quoi qu'il en soit
[Musique]
ces deux traversé la route et 324
millions de dollars
c'est aberrant c'est irresponsable
direz-vous qu'on a acheté une porsche
pour aller au dépanneur pire qu'à 300
millions pour des bateaux c'est pire que
çà mais nous avons dû réviser nos
chiffres après avoir questionné la
société des traversiers ce n'est plus
324 millions c'est encore pire que ça la
société nous apprend que la facture
finale c'est 351 millions nous sommes
allés les voir de plus près là bas un
employé des traversiers a accepté de
nous raconter l'envers du décor mais à
la condition de ne pas dévoiler son
identité et ont fait sont très modernes
même trop moderne tout électro nez puis
tous gérés par des ordinateurs
y'a plus rien manuel là dessus ça amène
bien des débris et bien des problèmes
c'est la ventilation le chauffage c'est
partout partout on a des problèmes à la
grandeur du navire c'est des bateaux
problématique les traversy sont
propulsés au gaz naturel une décision
coûteuse mais présenté comme un choix
écologique mais le problème du gaz d'un
problème de moteur aussi sa main de
milliers de problèmes puis des alarmes
puis tout ce qu'on veut comparativement
au fuel qu on avait zéro problème moi je
pense que c'est un investissement qui
comme ridicule pour une traversée de dix
minutes
notre expert est d'accord avec l'employé
de la société des traversiers le trajet
et traitements en cours que mettre des
systèmes très coûteux sophistiqués ça
tient pas
mais la question de fond qui se pose
c'est pourquoi on tolère de tels
dépassements de coûts mon premier emploi
est là davis 5 1 kg travail et leur
pendant les étés c'est un chant ty sont
capables de ils sont capables de
construire des bateaux mais est ce
qu'ils sont capables de construire des
bateaux un haut niveau économique
c'est ça la question qui on doit se
poser autrement dit des vip et pas vivre
6e pour soutien gouvernemental assez
important pour la construction soit
c'est un fait ça devient une question
sociale est ce qu'on veut payer pour ces
emplois là à la lumière l'expérience du
défago tient que vous qualifieriez de
quoi là en un mot
les facs gauthier un fiasco et de ces
deux traversiers là que vous
qualifieriez de un plus gros fiasco
financier qu'est ce que ça vous dit sur
la société des traversiers du québec
gestion projets ayant aucune notion
c'est une piste un opérateur d'un navire
mais c'est pas un constructeur de
navires
il y a un autre projet de traversée dans
l'air le remplacement du vacancier qui
dessert les îles de la madeleine
il est actuellement la propriété du
groupe ctm à une entreprise des îles
c'est un projet d'au moins 150 millions
de dollars en mai 2018
le gouvernement libéral a annoncé qu'il
soutiendrait financièrement la
construction du nouveau bateau et que
cctm à qui piloterait le projet d'appel
d'offres international sera lancé
exigent un contenu québécois de 30 pour
ça mais au final c'est passé
le chantier maritime a maintenant le
regard tourné vers québec pour
participer à la construction du nouveau
ctm à vacanciers qui fait le lien entre
montréal et les îles de la madeleine
davy multiplient les démarches y compris
juridiques pour contester ce contrat de
gré à gré alors que le processus
d'acquisition était déjà bien lancé par
ctm a les élus des îles de la madeleine
se disent inquiets à la suite de la
décision du chantier naval des vies de
se tourner vers les tribunaux pour faire
suspendre l'appel d'offres du groupe
c'est emma une bataille juridique qui
porte sur qui doit mener ce projet mais
le but pour des vies c'est d'obtenir le
contrat de construction du nouveau
vacanciers au terme d'un appel d'offres
qui se limiterait au canada selon la
requête l'entente comporte des
irrégularités elle précise notamment que
le rôle de la desserte revient
normalement à la société des traversiers
cette bataille navale entre des vies la
société des traversiers d'un côté et ctm
a de l'autre sera arbitrée par le
gouvernement caquistes qui reporte
depuis le printemps l'annoncent finale
mais pour john stop ce projet de navire
et le gros contrats qui s'en viennent
soulève beaucoup d'inquiétude quand on
enlève la concurrence mais on enlève la
possibilité d'avoir des meilleures
technologies les meilleurs aspects de
conception les meilleurs moteurs des
meilleurs professeurs quand on limite la
concurrence on limite nos possibilités
de succès alors suite on commence à
semer les ingrédients pour un pour un
nom d un str et puis une répétition de
notre interview d'homme 5 7 ans
[Musique]
non